Um,
so first off,
I mean it's an honor to be able to sit
here and with you and a and asking you
questions. Um, I think that a lot
of people in this room, you know,
probably owe their existence, their jobs.
Uh, t two what you've done in the past.
Um, I also speaking of somebody who's a
lot funnier in text form, um, thank you.
Uh, and uh, you know, I
think that uh, this being la,
I figured we should open with a question.
I think everyone is wondering right
now, which is a, who are you wearing?
Who are you wearing? What am I
wearing? Well, I hope it'll be obvious.
I don't know how many
layers deep do you want?
There is a story behind this though,
if you haven't heard it.
I was at Stanford University doing the
Internet design work and I was asked by
Arpa back in 1976 to come to Washington
to go run the program for them.
And my wife was from Wichita,
Kansas,
said Washington d c three piece suits.
And so she went off to a Saks fifth
avenue at the Stanford shopping center.
And bought three,
three piece suits,
one of which was a seersucker
outfit because she knew
that during the summertime
it was horrible, hot and Muggy
in Washington. So anyway,
I show up at Darpa in my three piece
suit and a few weeks later I'm asked to
testify before a some committee,
and I don't even remember
which one now, but, uh,
I wore my serious sucker
three piece suit and, uh,
did my testimony came back, you
know, nothing interesting happens.
And then if I get a request to
show up in the director's office,
the director of art, but not just the
information processing techniques office.
So I show up thinking, oh my God,
I did something wrong. You know,
it's the end of my
government career. And, uh,
he's got a letter in front
of it and then he says,
I don't let her hear from the
chairman. Uh, and he says,
thank you very much for doctor
service testimony, by the way,
he's the best dressed guy
we've ever seen from ARPA.
And I thought I took that
as positive feedback.
So I've been wearing
three pieces ever since.
Well, I, for one, uh, you know,
had a very similar interaction plan
away from it would have left work.
I left home this morning where she said,
no, you can't wear a hoodie. Uh, so,
so at least I can fit in. Um, so I
mean, let's start, uh, we're in La.
Um, I understand you have a, a
personal relationship with La.
I'd love to hear more about that. I'm
sorry. A personal relationship with La.
Yes, I do. In fact, although I
started out, you can do the math.
I started out at the Yale Hospital
in 1943 in new haven, Connecticut.
But after World War II,
my parents moved to Los Angeles.
So I grew up here in the
San Fernando Valley. Uh,
I moved around from North Hollywood
to Van Nuys and attended van Nuys High
School.
Uh,
and what's very interesting about that
school is that there were some other
people who turned down to be important
to the history of Internet who went to
that same school at nearly the same time.
So Steve Crocker,
who was my was and still is,
my best friend was in the client.
It's just behind mine.
He and I started the math
club and we both got to uh,
get access to computers at Ucla when
we were still a high school seniors.
Uh,
John Pastel,
who's another name I hope most of you
recognize also went to van Nuys high.
He was in the class after Steve's.
Um,
there were some other
interesting and then we all, we,
we didn't know John very well.
Steve and I were very close.
We all went off to college and then we
reassembled miraculously it UCLA and lend
Klein knocks a network
management lab and that's where,
of course a lot of the uh, arpanet
development took place, uh,
at least the host protocols,
space event.
And eventually those same people became
part of the, uh, Internet story. Uh,
it turns out there are some other
notable people who went to that same high
school, uh, before we did.
Then people like Robert Redford and
Marilyn Monroe and Don Drysdale,
and you can look it up if you
go look at advantage is high.
I had dinner with David
Skorton a few months ago.
He's now the secretary of the Smithsonian.
And we got to talking and he said
he grew up in La and he said, well,
where did you live? He said,
Sherman Oaks. And uh, I said,
what high school did you go
to? He says, Van Nuys High.
So about six years after I left,
but, but you know, so this is,
there must've been something interesting
going on in that neighborhood back in
the late fifties and early sixties.
So I have very strong
positive feelings about a,
about Los Angeles. Uh, and
right. Many of you, uh,
I scratch my head a little
bit about, uh, the, uh,
technical enterprise here. I mean,
we all know about Hollywood, uh,
the same head scratching goes
on further south in San Diego,
which is where I'm headed after
I finished my work here at, uh,
at Google in La.
Uh,
so I think we need to
do something to make,
I'm probably jumping into other
questions that you have, but,
but I think we need to do something to
make the La technical seen more visible
to people. There's a lot of
capacity here, uh, last June.
At the end of June, I went down to San
Diego and spent two and a half days there.
We called it surf's up in San Diego.
And I know bad puns minus two.
Uh,
but the idea was to have meetings with a
little round tables of 20 people coming
from different, um,
interested disciplines.
So a lot of it was biotech, some of it
was, you know, uh, quantum computing.
Some of it was advanced, a high
speed processing, networking,
and some of there were about 10 or 12
different topics that we picked on.
And then populated the round tables in.
My purpose was to find out
what was going on down there.
And then at the end of those two days,
uh,
I made it public lecture at Qualcomm
auditorium summarizing what I had learned.
And one thing that really surprised me,
it was there were 850 bio tech companies
in San Diego, most of them startups,
but some of them very big like scripts.
I haven't done that in Los
Angeles in a long time.
I was out here many years back and we did
something called surfs up in Hollywood.
Um, but I haven't returned to do
that. And that your, even your,
your line of questions make me think
that would be a timely thing to do.
The important part being to report what,
what was discovered in some way that's
visible to the venture community.
Some of you will know that Bill Maris,
uh, who used to run our Google ventures,
uh, has now started a
southern California, uh,
fund specifically to,
uh,
to focus on southern California
r and d activities. And so, uh,
I think that we should
take advantage of that.
We could certainly use your platform
as a way of making things more visible.
Well, I mean, I'm glad to say
that we do have an la office now,
so it's very exciting.
Um,
I'm wondering if is there any particular
area in tech that you see being
particularly suited to the La area?
So this is a really good question because
the answer is I don't know for sure,
which means that like many others,
I'm not sure what's going on in
Los Angeles or ignore, you know,
something in the San Fernando Valley
and La Proper or out here, you know,
in mountain view mountain
view. I know Santa Monica, uh,
historically there have been some
very important things going on here,
like rams for example.
Um,
but that was important to
specifically to the air force.
There's the jet propulsion
laboratory, which I spend time at, uh,
on the interplanetary Internet. So I know
a little bits and pieces, but not much.
In fact, one of the most visible
technical activities going on now,
and I won't say southern
California because Santa
Barbara isn't exactly southern
California,
but that's a place where there's some
deep work going on in quantum computing at
UC Santa Barbara and at
Google in that location. Um,
so I'm feeling,
I'm so glad that you're asking these
questions because I'm feeling this void of
knowledge that I suspect is actually
full of some pretty interesting stuff.
I mean,
we wouldn't have such a big office here
if there weren't a lot of interesting
things going on with a lot of very
smart people wanting to do something.
But I actually don't have a
good answer to that question.
I will argue that,
um,
given the fact that Hollywood is here,
that there is a lot of technology that's
bubbling up well past the old computer
graphics stuff, uh, that may
turn out to be very relevant.
One of them is magic leap, except
that's going on out in Florida. Uh,
but there are places including aerospace
that could potentially make use of some
of these new technologies,
but I haven't,
haven't had a chance to sit down
and actually probe what's going on.
So that's a really useful
idea. Uh, you mentioned, uh,
quantum computing and speaking
as a recovering physicist,
uh, it feels like, uh,
we've been talking about quantum computing
for a very long time and not making
much headway.
Uh,
do you think we'll see
something approaching quantum
computing in our lifetime?
I think there's no doubt about it.
Uh,
let me offer maybe two or three
observations. The first one is that,
uh, an early, uh,
computer that took advantage
of quantum effects.
I'm wording this very carefully is
the D-Wave system. Uh, in Canada,
there were huge arguments among
the physicist about, well,
this wasn't really quantum computing.
It was addy,
a bad luck and it was a
relaxation method. And so on, uh,
we acquired one of these
together with Nasa Ames, uh,
and began exploring algorithms
that we could use on that system.
And we found several algorithms
that offered a optimization of,
of things that we cared about that were
useful to us. In the meantime, however,
a Hartman, Nevin whose company we
acquired, uh, and turn it into Picasa,
uh,
here in Santa Monica,
got very interested in quantum computing
and was the reason we bought the d wave
machine. A hunt mode is now, uh,
the point guy on our quantum effort
in quantum development effort.
This is serious quantum computing.
We've had a seven cubit
system in operation.
We are shooting for a 49 cubits system.
There's an unfortunate term called
quantum supremacy, which sounds, you know,
like we want to dominate
the world or something.
We had really speaks to the number of
cubits that you need in order to carry out
computations.
That would be uh,
either too time consuming or maybe even
nearly impossible using conventional
methods. Uh, I think they are,
they were shooting to get that actually
in operation by the end of the year.
I'm now, I suspect they hope to
get some sometime this year. Uh,
so this is an important effort because
there are certain kinds of computations
that lend themselves to this
kind of rapid computing.
One of which everybody here might
know is called the shores. Algorithm.
Shores Algorithm is a way of,
of a factoring very,
very large products with primes or in
factory numbers to determine whether they
are prime or non. Uh, it turns out
that a lot of the security systems,
including public key algorithms like Rsa
are in fact based on the difficulty of
factoring products of large primes.
So if shores algorithm could be
run in a real quantum machine,
then you could in fact break some of
the cryptography by a good fortune.
There are other branches of mathematics
that can be adapted to a cryptog
cryptographic purposes.
One of which is lattice mathematics.
And so there's already a parallel
effort to do post quantum, uh,
security and cryptography
using an alternative. Uh,
nonetheless,
uh,
there are other much more valuable
algorithms that maybe feasible with the
quantum systems,
with enough cubits in them.
So I'm now persuaded that we will
see a serious and useful, uh,
quantum calculations being done.
Certainly before the end of this decade.
I was up at bell labs,
um,
just last week and had a look at
another quantum system that they've been
working on and, uh, I'm not an
expert in this space, so, uh,
I'm not sure I will be
able to capture very well,
um,
what they were doing,
but to suffice it to say that quantum
calculation depends on maintaining,
uh, the, uh, entangled
state of the cubits.
And if you can maintain that
entangled state for long enough,
then you can actually do a
computation and get some answers back.
But typically the duration of a quantum
state manipulation is on the order of
milliseconds, tens of
milliseconds, things like that. Um,
and this particular thing that the guys
at bell labs are doing could have more
like seconds to minutes of a
persistence of quantum state,
in which case they would have the ability
to do much more serious computations.
Uh, so there I think
there is a is real. Um,
I have real expectations that we
will be applying quantum methods,
uh, within a few years
time, uh, at Google.
Some of you will know that we've,
uh,
invested in a variety of different
computational platforms. The CPU,
Gpu, yes. Now TPU for the tensor
processing units for machine learning.
And I fully expect that CUPE use
will be there at some point as well.
I mean in another one
of those, uh, you know,
harbingers of doom and our industry
is always talking about AI and the
progression of Ai.
And that's also seems like
up until recently that was
something that was in the
distant future. How do you see the
development of AI in recent years?
Well, I was around, uh, Ian,
it's in the 1960s,
which,
which sounds like it was sometime near
the civil war, even though that that's,
you know,
a hundred years later
here's were actually a
series of Tutsis. So, um,
at Stanford there was a
great deal of excitement. Uh,
John McCarthy and Ed Feigenbaum
and others were founders of,
of artificial intelligence.
They were thinking mostly general
artificial intelligence where a computer
program would learn to reason about
a world model that it formed from its
interactions with the real
world. Uh, but I remember, uh,
an early attempt at machine
language translation. Uh,
we naively,
I didn't participate in this so that
I'm just giving you the observer's
perspective,
but they naive laid it just loaded a
Russian English dictionary a into the
computer in the hope that it
would just do natural translation.
So then they fed in a,
and an English language
expression out of sight,
out of mind, and they translated it
interruption through this dictionary.
Then they translated it back and
it came back invisible idiot.
And that's when they realized there was
probably more to this translation thing.
And then just the dictionary.
Well,
a series of evolutions occurred in
this natural language translation,
one of which was a statistical methods
where you have a large corpus of
documents that are the same documents
in multiple languages and you use a
simple,
relatively simple statistical way of
saying this phrase and this language is
frequently associated with
that phrase in this language.
And you use these statistics
in order to do the translation.
This got us a fairly significant
improvement in the quality of translation.
And then we sort of flattened
down, uh, subsequent to that,
the development of large
high, you know, what's right,
large numbers, large numbers
of layers, multilayer networks.
Um, we're talking about hundreds
of layers, for example, uh,
allowed us to do even better
translations at what surprised me,
uh,
about this particular kind of machine
learning is that instead of having a
different neural network
for each language pair,
which is what I imagined
would be necessary. So if
we do a hundred languages,
that's 10,000 different pairs in
both, you know, each direction.
Um,
we ended up building one gigantic neural
network and feeding it all language
pairs. And I thought, well,
this is hopeless, you know,
how could that possibly work?
But with enough layers
in a neural network,
my little cartoon model,
this is my understanding of this is,
is fairly superficial than
my little cartoon model says
that the more layers you
have in the neural network, the more
state information you can remember.
And so the,
as you feed these systems more and
more examples and you train them, yes,
you've got to right or no,
you got it wrong. Uh, this,
this experience is encoded in the
various weights that show up in different
places in the layers
of the neural network.
So we discovered that by allowing
multiple languages to be trained on this
single neural network, that we get
improvement in all language pairs.
Something interesting is going
on there. Uh, on the other hand,
there are also places
where mistakes happen.
So here we are in 2018 we still
don't have perfection. Uh,
I was in Heidelberg last
year and I was looking up,
uh, the weather report to see what was
the weather going to be for that day.
And so since I was in Heidelberg
doing going little Google search,
it directed me to what
was a German website.
I didn't actually notice that because
it was translated so quickly that I was
seeing English. And so I thought it
was a, an English language website.
And I was looking at the report,
it said it was zero chance of rain and a
zero chance of fog and there was also a
zero chance of ice cream.
And you know,
I looked at that and so I took
this to my German friends and says,
you have ice cream storms here.
Well, it turns out that, uh,
that the word ice EIS in German could
be interpreted either as ice cream or as
hale.
And the natural language processing system
didn't have enough context apparently
to figure out which one it was,
though it said ice cream.
So of course I took a screenshot of that
and he sent it to our natural language
processing guys, uh, to remind them
that we had not achieved perfection yet.
But I can say with,
with some assurance that our machine
learning methods are becoming incredibly
powerful. Uh, just to
remind you a year or so ago,
uh,
the deepmind team built the Alpha goal
system and taught him how to play go at
grand master level.
We had contests in South
Korea and in China,
the machine one, almost all of the
contests with these grand masters,
I think except for one,
which at least at all manage to
get one out of five successfully.
But that in itself was not
the most dramatic example
for me of what is happening
with that technology. Uh, the most
dramatic example is called Alpha zero.
And in this case, uh, instead
of spending weeks, uh,
training the programs and,
and letting them play each other,
different versions of the program,
playing each other millions of games, uh,
over a period of three days
starting only with the rules of go,
they got Alpha zero to learn how
to play a grandmaster level go,
which is astonishing to make matters
even more than salmon mushing.
Starting with the rules of chess.
Alpha zero learned in a few hours to
play better than any of the known,
uh, computer based just
plain systems. You know,
this is not to say that that particular,
uh,
three hour learning system would produce,
w could be an international
grandmaster human player,
but the fact that a few hours that
they could train it to play chess, uh,
that well who is really quite astonishing.
So that tells you that there is great
power in machine learning in many,
many different applications.
We still don't entirely understand all
the things that are going on in the
machine learning space. So in
these neural networks, for example,
if you train it to distinguish
the classical cat from a dog, um,
it's,
it's then possible to alter a small
number of pixels in the challenge picture
and have the system.
Ms Is,
this is the small number of pixels is
not distinguishable to you. Human being,
it's still looks like a dog to us,
but the machine learning system
could say it's a kangaroo.
And so there is something
going on, uh, with the,
the weight of the Pixel,
each pixel in the image
as it's being processed,
working through this neural network.
There's little places somewhere in the,
in the chain that are particularly
sensitive to those pixels.
And if you change those pixels, it causes
the system to make their own decision.
This is a little bit like chaos theory,
and I'm not trying to draw more than
just a superficial analogy here,
but in chaos theory, you know that a
chaotic system will produce very, uh,
widely varying outputs based on very,
very small changes in the input.
And so it's not continuous.
And so we're seeing a similar
kind of thing going on now
that's machine learning.
Some of it's spectacularly good, like
being able to detect, uh, um, uh,
a problem that diabetic retinopathy,
for example,
we trained a neural network to
look at images of people's retinas.
And then we had a ophthalmologists,
something 85 of them assess whether or
not this image demonstrated or did not
demonstrate, uh, the diabetic
retinopathy syndrome.
Then we trained a neural network on
the basis of that data and the neural
network did a better job than the,
uh, uh, ophthalmologist did, uh,
on, uh, new subsequent examples.
So we clearly have a
very powerful technology.
None of this is what I would call
general purpose, artificial intelligence.
The thing that you and I do that machines
don't right now is to take from a
small number of samples,
the ability to model what we are
experiencing and then to reason about that
model. And so the example here,
this thing is a table. Why do we,
what is the main property of table?
Well, it's a sort of a flat surface. Uh,
and the,
the thing that we quickly understand
is that there are many things.
It could be a table, could be, uh,
an orange crate could be
anything with a flat surface.
And the other thing we've understood
implicitly is that if something has a flat
bottom,
then it can be placed on a table and
the table will support it if it's not a
flat bottom and may fall over,
roll off the table.
So we very quickly get
this idea very quickly,
but machines don't because at the moment
they don't formulate models that you
can reason about.
And I think that's the
next big breakthrough is
understanding how to present
information to assist them.
That can reason about it.
Now if you look at a self driving car.
So I'm really answering the hope
you don't mind. I mean it's,
this is what happened.
It's a big question for former former
Stanford professors can rattle on for 50
minutes on any topic even if
they know nothing about it.
So I promise I won't
do 15 minutes on this,
but the self driving cars of course
had been in the headlines partly as a
consequences,
that very sad accident that happened
to a new Uber self driving car. Uh,
what's interesting about the Waymo
effort at Google or at Alphabet,
uh, is the, uh,
amount of image recognition
and inference that the systems,
uh, exercise. And so there's
a classification effort.
These are the field of view is
gathering data visually with Lidar.
Uh, and of course a detailed
knowledge of where our,
where am I and what are the streets
that I should be on and so on. Uh,
these systems classify images in the,
in the field and then make predictions
about what those classified objects might
do. So this is somebody on a bicycle.
This is a pedestrian. This is a truck.
This is a car.
Um,
the modeling that goes on is very
important because the system is predicting
possible future outcomes of the,
uh,
of what those objects might do.
And it's planning what to do if any
of those particular things eventuate.
And that is a form of model building.
And so we're,
I think we're edging into some
interesting territory now that is not done
exclusively by machine
learning neural networks.
It's also done by very deliberate
programming. Uh, again,
with my knowledge of this
is relatively superficial,
so I can't quite tease apart for you
which parts are deliberate programming and
which parts are inferred
learning from machine learning.
But the mix is quite
powerful. Uh, finally, uh,
everyone who sees some of these results,
whether it's a self driving car or a
impressive a game playing board plane
skills, uh, or uh, or, uh,
medical image analysis,
everyone should appreciate that
these are extremely narrow, uh,
behaviors. These are very powerful
but very narrow behaviors.
And human beings exhibit an incredibly
broad range of abilities to abstract from
the real world that they sense
build models in reason about them.
And so we're a long ways away I think
from having that capability in place.
So, uh, I have to thank you again for, uh,
for the name because I think if we do
have a reddit skunkworks AI project,
we'll have to call it invisible an idiot.
Um, you know, we talk a lot
in tech about the future.
Uh, I'm wondering if there's any, uh,
technologies that you've seen in your
career that never really caught on, uh,
and what,
what those were that should have maybe,
well, there are, are several that
have, uh, of course it's clearly the,
the machine learning, uh, TPU
stuff is pretty dramatic. Uh,
recently I was just at the open networking
summit this morning in downtown La.
Um, and been, I had been looking at, um,
switching hardware,
which is programmable now I had for a
long time essentially dismissed software
defined networking as a kind of
marketing buzzword because after all,
all the routers that I'd ever encountered
or the ones that we used to call
gateways, cause we didn't know they
were supposed to be called routers. Uh,
we're all software. I mean, they're
programmed to do stuff. And so I thought,
what's the big deal?
Well,
there is a big deal here because
some of these platforms are very,
very powerful switching engines and
all they know how to do is switch,
but they don't do anything unless you
explain to them what they're supposed to
do. And so they are more
programmable, uh, in the,
in a very fundamental way
than a classic switch,
which is using software in almost
exclusively to do the switching.
Whereas this is hardware that does the
switching in accordance with a software
program that tells it how it should
evaluate the bits in the packet to decide
where they're supposed to go.
But it uses the hardware to
do the actual forwarding.
So I'm now persuaded that
that is a paradigm shift in,
uh, in the implementation of switching
systems for community communications.
And now I'm persuaded there's some
very interesting horsepower, uh,
to be applied there. So
that's one technology. Uh,
there is another one about which
I know, again, very, not much, uh,
but the magic leap guys, uh, in Florida,
uh,
had written an article in wired.
I think if some of you may have
already seen it, uh, if you haven't,
you might take, if you're curious about
this, you might take the time to look.
They've been able to, uh,
produce images for us, you know,
by wearing
glasses,
not Google glass in the classic sense,
but something which,
which is computer controlled, which
puts relatively opaque images, uh,
in front of you embedded
in the actual visual scene.
So we're talking about, um, not, uh,
not purely virtual reality,
but augmented reality where these virtual
objects injected into the field of
view and you can walk towards them and
into them and they'd be there quite
realistic. Um, I don't know
where that's all going to end up,
but I'm persuaded that our ability to,
um,
take the real world as it looks and
then present information about it,
uh, is a, uh,
a powerful and not yet
well exploited idea. Uh,
imagine being able to stand down,
you know, the top of the building,
looking out over the field of view
and ask a question, what's that?
And get back useful information. Or
if you're navigating in a, in a city,
you've never been to, uh, the ability
to get guidance, uh, in real time.
It's pretty attractive. Now I have
to admit to you though that, um,
I've seen a lot of these, um, things
that you hang on your head for,
for virtual reality that make
you look like Darth Vader. And,
and I remember thinking,
I wonder how video conferencing is going
to work if everybody is wearing this
thing.
Then what do you look like to the other
people who are part of the conference?
And of course you don't want
to look like Darth Vader.
So suddenly there's a whole new business
to be made where you're virtual avatar
that is presented in lieu of you because
you're wearing this weird thing on your
face. Um, I'm not sure
where that's going to go,
but I can imagine me wanting to
have more hair, for example. Uh,
so there could be a whole
new set of businesses. This,
this stuff is reminiscent of what's also
happening with the Internet of things
and automation in general. Everybody's
worried that all these jobs go away.
The robots are coming. Uh, the robots are
coming. There's no question about that.
But I see them as partners
and not as threats.
It is true that some work that it is
classically done by people today will end
up being done by machines and robots.
Some of that work by the way, we'll
be done without physical involvement.
Too many people misunderstand
robot as only thing which you know,
can affect the real world by
physically interacting with it.
But a program trading system in the
stock market is as much a robot as a,
as your favorite, a Boston
dynamics, a big dog.
It should be obvious that those programs
are taking input from the real world,
the stock transactions,
analyzing it and taking actions was
have a real world effect on your bank
account, for example, or on the economy.
That's as much a robot as anything else
and we should be thinking along those
lines. So, um,
I'm strongly persuaded that we
will see a robotic technology,
uh,
becoming increasingly useful to us,
including the kinds of things
that involve, um, for example,
a smart search where more semantics are
injected into the search process then
has been the case in the past.
So it used to be that we would just look
for search terms and tell you here's
all the pages,
have those terms in them.
Now we use something
called the knowledge graph,
which contains a great deal of semantic
information so that the terms that you
use are run through the knowledge graph
in order to get a better semantic depth
before we actually do the, uh, the
search in the index of the worldwide web,
uh, attempting to get a better
semantic response for you. So those,
those are all examples of tools that are,
I am persuaded will become more and
more common place. We do have, uh,
an interesting problem and that is how
do we take care of people whose jobs have
been superannuated, uh, by
automatic techniques or program, uh,
methods.
Uh,
and the answer to that clearly is better
education or more education retraining.
And things like that. Uh, not to sound
like this is too much of a nostrum.
I would like to point out to you that,
uh,
the historical trend for humans is to
live longer because of improved medical
care, sanitation, diet
and everything else. Uh,
that means that kids that are born today
may very well easily live to a hundred
years old, which of course it puts them
into the 22nd century. My science fiction,
uh, you know, bulb over here is
sending, wow, that's amazing.
Imagine being alive in the 22nd century.
What's that going to be like? Um,
but what that does is force you to think
a little bit about careers that might
last 80 years.
And you realize that over an 80
year period or a 70 year period,
lots of technology changes will occur.
I mean,
all we have to do is look back 11 years
and realized that we didn't have smart
phones until 2007.
So over that period of time,
watts is going to happen
and it's unlikely to,
anyone's job is going to stay purse,
you know,
persistent over that period of time will
be forced to have to learn new things.
So maybe we should just start out on the
premise that we are going to be working
in learning and working and learning
and working and learning for our entire
careers and start out not by trying to
jam everything that you're possibly could
need to know for a 50 year career in uh,
you know,
a 20 year period.
But instead make it normal
to keep learning new things,
teaching kids how to want to
learn how to learn and how to,
how to feel comfortable with the idea
that they will go to work, go to school,
go to work, go to school is
a normal part of their lives.
That's just that four year colleges and
jamming everything into four years may
not be the right model. You've seen
college expenses going up dramatically.
Maybe we need to rethink how we do
this. How are we distributing, learning,
distributing, learning over a
lifetime. And that suggests to me that,
uh,
our,
our society will look pretty different
in a few years talking to as a result of
that.
It's a, it's a great segway into talking
about the people centered Internet,
which I know is something that you've,
you've co founded and started putting
a lot of, uh, of time into. Um,
could you tell us about that?
So, uh, one of my colleagues, um,
they're not at Google but elsewhere
Malin phones who used to be at Oracle and
it's one of the founders of customer
relationship management. Uh,
and I got together and started this
small little thing called people centered
Internet. And the focus of
attention frankly is on, um,
making the internet useful for people.
And I confess to you that, uh, Oh yes,
I don't know what it is that a
signal that I should stop or a,
I think there's a hook ready to
go if we had to get off stage. Um,
my job at Google,
uh,
as the chief Internet evangelist is
often to deal with policy questions,
some of which are, uh, how to
get more internet out there,
how to create an environment
where investment is welcome, uh,
how to get governments to encourage
competition and investment.
But it malins point,
which I took very seriously,
is that it's not enough just to get the
internet out there is the question is
what can you do with it is materially
beneficial that improves people's lives in
a way that you could
really point to, uh, in,
in a quantitative way
and a qualitative way.
So our focus of attention
is how to improve the use
of Internet for the benefit
of the population that has access to it.
Whether that's better knowledge for
healthcare, learning for a job change,
a variety of other, uh, kinds of uses.
And so our focus is to try to make sure
that as we are pushing hard to get more
internet out there,
which we need to do because only half
the world's population has got access to
it.
We're also thinking hard about a local
content content in local languages.
Nobody would find it very
useful. Living in Quito, uh,
looking for a plumber and
getting the answer. There's
a plumber in New York City.
I mean, you need to get an
answer this locally useful.
So we care a great deal about that.
To be honest. This same effort,
this people centered Internet is edging
into another category which you may
already have questions about.
It has to do with the emergence
of a fake news of, uh,
you know, botnets and echo chambers
and all these other things, uh,
which are very troubling and which we
are going to have to deal with because we
can't around a society to disintegrate
simply because of the arrival of some of
these effects. You may have
questions that, so I won't
go any further on there. Uh,
but I am prepared to talk at more
length on that topic if necessary.
It's doing my job for me. Yeah. Um,
well actually I'd like to hear more about
what you think are the current set of,
of challenges and the
barriers to actually, uh,
I'm more continuing to
grow the open Internet.
So it's funny, some people ask
me, chief Internet evangelist,
why do you need to evangelize the
Internet? Isn't it obvious? You know,
that everybody should have access to
it. Uh, and of course the answer is, uh,
even if it were obvious,
it's not always true that you in every
place in the world where Internet isn't
a, there is an appreciation
and an understanding of, um,
the value of implementing and,
uh,
and of course with the negative things
that are showing up in the news now
there's even a pushback saying maybe this
isn't the right thing to do at all. Uh,
this was an example of a kind of
emergent property that it's common for
engineers to miss and they,
this is a apology I get,
did I miss this?
Uh,
so this is my way of trying to
escape too much culpability. Um,
I thought it was very important to
push the barrier to access to this
capability,
this computer mediated communication
to nearly zero so that everybody could
afford to get into the system,
could afford to get access
to information and services,
could share knowledge in the system to
try to just get those barriers down to
zero.
Uh,
what I didn't appreciate at
the time is that in so doing,
uh,
all of the bad elements of our society
benefited from this same reduction in
barrier.
And so before we had internet
and the worldwide web,
your ability to reach a large audience,
depending on your ownership of the
television station or radio station,
a newspaper publishing empire
magazines or something, uh,
access to mass media was
not available to everyone.
Internet makes it possible for people to
make use of this enormous distribution
engine, uh, virtually
anybody with a smartphone.
And the side effect of that,
of course,
is that there are people out there
who deliberately want to pollute the
information environment
for their own purposes,
who want to build botnets and use them
to pollute the system to a launch denial
of service attacks to create
false reinforcement of,
uh, of false information, uh,
to reinforce or maybe
exacerbate and disturbed, um,
isolated groups of people
who, you know, who,
who think alike about certain things
and are resistant to any other ideas.
These echo chamber effects simply
amplify that and reinforce,
this is called confirmation
bias, uh, in, in some circles.
So we now have a problem because
everybody, including these bad elements,
have access to the system,
which they it with which they can amplify
their information in a very funny way.
This creates a big asymmetry.
Uh, what used to be,
uh,
available only to a nation state is
suddenly available to a small groups of
people, even individuals. So the question
is, what do we do about that? Uh,
in other infrastructure where we
have discovered that there is abuse,
uh, we typically ended up saying, well,
the following things are unacceptable.
In our society. Now,
sometimes if we're lucky,
we can actually do take technical
measures to inhibit some of the bad side
effects. So for example,
uh, seatbelts in cars,
we try to big persuasive campaign showing
teenagers who were about to get their
licenses. This is what you look like if
you drive badly, get drunk and you know,
kill yourself or your friends.
Uh,
and so this is why it's important
to learn how to drive safely,
how not to drink and drive and so on.
As much as,
as we would teach that we also put
laws in place that said, by the way,
if we catch you driving without your
seat belt, there will be consequences.
So we have these technical means.
We have these post-talk posting,
post hoc enforcement, uh,
in, in the Internet case,
we're starting to see more
of the post hoc stuff,
which is we track people
down who've done a bad thing.
It's hard to figure out how to do this
in an international setting because we're
crossing boundaries that the
legal regimes don't cross.
And so this Internet, which knows nothing
about international boundaries at all,
um, creates hazards that we
didn't normally experience.
So somebody in one country can
attack somebody in another country.
And unless there are agreements between
those two countries and may be very
difficult,
even if we know who the perpetrator is
to actually go after them and exercise
those consequences.
So those are two of the mechanisms that
you can see evolving. You can see, uh,
an interest in treaty arrangements.
There is one called the mutual
legal assistance treaty or MLS,
which turns out to be
incredibly slow and clumsy. Uh,
it may take weeks to months in order to
get access to information that you
need to track down a perpetrator it,
whereas these things happen in
the Internet in mental seconds.
So there's a lot of attention
being paid now to, uh,
how to improve our ability to do
cross border, uh, law enforcement.
There is a third thing that you can do
and that's a moral suasion that don't do
that. It's just bad. It's wrong.
And what's interesting of
course is that sounds very weak,
but I would draw your attention to
one of the important forces of nature.
Your gravity.
It's the weakest force in the universe.
And yet when you have large
mass gravity is pretty powerful.
It's what keeps us from falling
off the planet, for example.
So you can imagine the a social analogy
where there is a common and broad
agreement on the following, things
not being acceptable socially. Uh,
we may actually get a certain amount
of social pressure to inhibit those bad
behaviors.
But like every other infrastructure we've
ever designed and built a internet can
be abused. It's like people would
get drunk and drive their cars.
We can't stop them,
but we can tell them if we catch you,
there will be consequences.
So that's the sort of thing which I
think we are now faced with is how to,
how to use this tool to its best advantage
and how to respond when people abused
the tool in a very funny way.
This reinforces my enjoyment
of Shakespeare because,
you know,
Shakespeare wrote his plays 400 years
ago and yet they're still popular today
because there's still relevant.
All the bad things they are about human
beings are reflected in those plays and
there's still relevant to the
situation we find ourselves in today.
So we actually a source some questions
from the reddit community and some of
them are actually really pertinent
to this topic. Um, and uh,
one actually that comes up here is a
doctor Huna on our technology asks.
Uh, okay, so net neutrality, uh,
what needs to be done to preserve our
free flow of information but also to
enable businesses to flourish with it.
Okay.
So this is a, this is question
number 105 being it comes up a lot.
Number one on one is did you have any
idea that this was going to get this big
unequal? Yeah. So, um,
I won't pull the graduate student trick
on you by answering question one on one
instead of one oh five. And most
graduate students when asked a question,
we'll try to distort the question around
to the point where they can answer it.
Um,
I hope I haven't insulted in any graduate
students here was once a Grad student.
So the answer on the net
neutrality side, um, I think,
I hope a lot of you recognize
how we ended up here. Uh,
I'll try to make this not too long.
There is a fairly long chain here.
Um, in the 1990s, mid 1990s,
there were 8,000 Internet
service providers in the
u s because Internet was a
dial up service.
And so you just had to rent a bunch of
modem banks in order to be an Internet
service provider. Uh, and if you as
the consumer didn't like the service,
you could go to somebody else
by dialing a different number.
And so the switching back and
forth between this, the, uh,
service providers was quiet very easy and
therefore this is a highly competitive
thing. When broadband technology
came along and cable modems,
fiber modems and a DSL,
for example,
the number of providers
you telescope down to,
very few for any individual,
there was a choice of zero,
one or two really a telco or a cable co,
uh,
or if you were in the
rural parts of the country,
nobody was offering new
broadband service at all.
So we didn't have a
highly competitive market.
And as these companies began to
verticalize as they began to, um,
not only offer their original things like
telephone calls and in the case cable
companies, uh, video, uh, as they
started to also offer Internet service,
broadband, Internet service,
uh, you start to run into, uh,
April cancel hazard.
Let's take a cable company that was
offering video services plus high speed
Internet,
noticing that his customer is using the
high speed Internet service to look at
somebody else's videos. And so, you know,
the temptation is a potential temptation
there to go mess up the Internet
service enough so that the competitor's
videos won't work and force your
customer to only
subscribe to your service.
I'm not suggesting that anybody would
actually do that, although there were,
there, there were some
cases along these lines, uh,
or blocking for that matter.
Like voiceover Ip was blocked by some
telephone companies even though they were
also offering Internet
service. So at some point, um,
the cable companies and the telcos
complained to the FCC that they were each
offering internet service, but they
were regulated by different regimes.
Cause in the telecom act there's a cable
telecom regulation in title six and
there's a,
uh,
a telecommunications regulation
for roughly to left knee
speaking into entitled
to.
So they were whining to the FCC that they
had different regulatory regimes even
though they were both offering Internet
service. And so the FCC decided,
well,
let's fix that by not regulating internet.
So they moved into call
what's called title one,
which is an unregulated information
service that did not pay any attention to
the fact that the Internet is
in fact the layered structure.
And there is a telecommunications
component to it. But
then at the same time,
this same FCC said, well, but
let's institute some rules,
we'll call them the net neutrality rules.
Don't block,
don't interfere with
other people's traffic,
don't stop your customer from going to
any legitimate place on the net. Uh,
so the subsequent FCC,
when it encountered abuses trying to
enforce the net neutrality rules and said,
you can't do that, either we will
find you or a cease and desist.
And the, uh, one of the
abusers basically said,
you don't have any grounds for finding or,
or otherwise interfering because you
said this is an unregulated service.
You have no regulatory authority.
This went all the way up to the Supreme
Court and the Supreme Court and said,
Yup. Uh, the, uh, the, the, uh,
provider information in Internet service
provider was correct because the FCC
had essentially said, this is not
regulated. You have no authority.
So the subsequent FCC said,
well, that sucks. So they,
well, I'm sure they said it
in a little more delicate way,
but then they voted to move this back
to title to say move Internet service to
title two and say it
is a regulated service,
but we will forbear from regulating or
from applying all the regulations of
title two,
which include all the price controls.
And all kinds of other things in
the historical telephony world.
The more recent FCC decided
they didn't like that very much.
And so they voted on,
um,
party learnings to rescind the decision
that the Internet is a regulated title
to service. So it's now back to
being an unregulated service.
The side effect of that is that we are
no longer protected by any ability of the
FCC to,
um,
respond to various kinds of
potential harms to consumers.
Now to be accurate about it,
the theory is that the federal
trade commission can now engage,
but the way the federal trade
commission and gauges is a case by case
adjudication of, uh, what it
is thought to be an abuse of,
uh,
or consumer harm.
And I'm not persuaded this gives
much guidance to the Internet service
providers.
So I confessed to you that I would
prefer to see an FCC component to it.
Um,
I was split this into two parts.
One of them is making sure that the
basic infrastructure and access to the
Internet is neutral in the sense that it
doesn't interfere with consumer choice.
It doesn't interfere with the quality
of the service, doesn't permit, uh,
kinds of, um, uh, special, uh,
favors to somebody who pays you
to do a better job for them. Um,
at the same time,
if there are consumer abuses that have
to do with content or fraud or other
kinds of consumer harm,
that's perfectly reasonable to
show up as an FTC proceeding.
So I would split this into two
parts with regard to the FCC part.
I would not leave it entitled to,
I think a separate title
is appropriate for, uh,
for Internet regulation of very
lightweight, uh, regulation.
The problem is that in order
to achieve such an objective,
we would need the congress to pass a law.
And the moment it tends to pass gas,
but not much law.
So until we have a congress,
it's capable of actually doing something,
the likelihood that we
will have a suitable, uh,
regulatory framework for Internet
is remote. So that's where we stand
on the later side. Yeah. You, Dante asks,
what is the best thing you've seen
come from the Internet? Alternatively,
what's the worst? I will add the addition.
They don't have to be different. Okay.
Oh, that's interesting.
Uh, well in, in some sense,
just an honest response to your,
your last observation.
The thing which is wonderful about
the internet is its openness.
The thing which is terrible about
the internet is its openness. Uh,
there another formulation of that is the
wonderful thing about the internet is
everything is connected.
The worst thing about the internet
is everything is connected. Uh,
this is particularly visible as you start
thinking about the Internet of things.
All of these devices that
we're surrounded with. Uh,
I used to joke that the headline I was
fearful of is 100,000 refrigerators
attack.
Bank of America,
I no longer tell that
because as you all know,
500,000 webcams attack
the dining corporation.
So it's not funny at all.
Um,
so we talked a little bit about
the side effect of the freedom,
uh, that, uh,
has been given to all of us to both
inject information into the net,
into finding information back.
And it is in fact a Yin
and Yang kind of thing, uh,
that we now have to
learn how to cope with.
I still think on balance that the reduced
barriers to the sharing of knowledge
is a gift to our society.
And that in a way we have to learn how
to use that gift more effectively and to
deal with the potential side effects.
I would not want to go back to a
world that has no internet in it.
And I hope that's true for
everybody else in this audience.
So those are the immediate
thoughts that come to mind. Um,
the other thing which I love
about the Internet, he is,
it's architecture has invited new ideas
should be injected into the system.
If you didn't like the set of services
that were available and you thought new
protocols where you needed,
you were always free and you are still
free to invent new protocols and they can
be lodged into the architecture
wherever they're needed or desired. Uh,
it even at the Ip layer, which
is really hard to change. Uh,
there has been the significant injection
of change and that's what the Ip
version six, uh, it's,
we're still pushing on that wet noodle
is that it's taken this since 1996 to get
to where we are now,
which is about 30% penetration.
I am fairly convinced that
between mobile phones,
smart phones and Internet of things
that everyone will recognize.
It's important to move to IPV six so that
we'll have enough address space to do
all the things that we hope to do.
I have to admit to you that there was a
time once when I said, uh, that IPV six,
which has 3.4 times 10 to the 38th
addresses, uh, should be enough.
So wherever you electron in the
universe can have its own web page.
And I got an email from
somebody to caltech shortly
after that same dear doctor
serve you jerk.
They're there,
they're 10 to the 88 electrons in the
universe and you're off by 50 orders of
magnitude.
So I don't tell that story anymore.
Well.
Thank you all
[inaudible].